muy buenas noches desde londres desde
luego ya había sospechas de estas
fiestas porque se filtraron muchísimos
detalles a la prensa en semanas
anteriores simplemente el informe hoy
confirma la sospecha de la población y
por lo tanto hay indignación porque
mientras la población se encontraba en
confinamiento y no podía reunirse con
sus seres queridos acudir a funerales o
despedirse de sus enfermos en downing
street se realizaban estas fiestas con
alcohol y con música y esto es lo que
confirma este informe que había exceso
de alcohol en un lugar de trabajo en la
residencia oficial de downing street-
unas fiestas o reuniones que no debieron
haber ocurrido y hoy en el congreso
desde luego la oposición ha pedido de
nueva cuenta la renuncia del primer
ministro boris johnson pero también hay
voces y voces del partido conservador de
los diputados que abiertamente algunos
de ellos han pedido la renuncia del
primer ministro
marcela se sabe que la policía también
está indagando sobre estas presuntas
fiestas pero qué es exactamente lo que
se está investigando
lo que se está investigando son 12 de 16
fiestas que pudieron haber violado las
leyes del confinamiento estas leyes y
estas reglas que se interpusieron desde
lo más alto desde el gobierno y que toda
la población tenía que cumplir y también
sabemos si ha trascendido que se va a
investigar una fiesta en particular que
ocurrió en el departamento del primer
ministro boris johnson y su esposa carla
y estas investigaciones aunque la
policía ha dicho que no habrá
actualizaciones estamos a la espera y
sobre todo el primer ministro lo ha
dicho que ahora está a la espera del
resultado de estas investigaciones
policiacas por lo tanto ha ganado tiempo
el primer ministro de nuestra crisis
política que ya dura varias semanas
desde que se conocieron los detalles de
estas supuestas o estas fiestas
clandestinas